et alors les prix mépris ils sont là
tous ceux qui ont été alphonse allais la
machine ça c'est alors ça c'est un truc
auquel je tiens c'est là c'est le prix
de la presse internationale
là aussi c'est une médaille mais oui il
ya ça sert à ça sert à rien en fait
[Musique]
j'ai travaillé de 9 ans à 18 ans j'ai
fait des tas de films
les tournées dans des tas de films
docteur laennec à dieu a besoin des
hommes
orphée de cocteau etc
j'étais l'occupation et tous les
cinéastes tournée sur la côte d'azur
parce que c'était ce qu'on appelait la
zone libre à nice il y avait pas de
figure ont donc les marcel carné choisi
ccc figurant dans la population
et moi j'en faisais partie de cette
population alors à 9 ans j'ai été je
transportais un petit cochon en carton
dans le visiteur du soir dans le lit
mais le fameux dîner où il y avait le
diable après j'ai tourné les enfants du
paradis aussi et après une série de
films à laurianne faisait tourner avec
gérard philipe
on m'a fait faire le double gérant cible
de loin ma rencontre et cocteau était
extraordinaire parce qu'on tournait à la
porte des villages et et figurants il y
avait jean marc et j'en étais sûr une
place et on écrase un personnage et il
devait y avoir quelqu'un qui me dans la
foule quelqu'un disait mais une place où
une passe et jamais personne
cocteau il m'a regardé me tienne tu vas
dire ça toi et je dis ça et je suis dans
le film depuis
[Musique]
c'est les italiens qui ont fait ma
future carrière française parce qu'en
fait c'était une époque où les italiens
n'avaient que des acteurs des petits des
acteurs brin style ouvriers plutôt est
donc en pis y avait un noble ou
quelqu'un qui devait faire un en compte
ou alors il faisait appel à des français
on était plusieurs et on était engagé à
la mais là bas c'est à dire on était
payé chaque mois un peu comment
hollywood et finalement on n'avait rien
il y avait des mots on avait rien à
[ __ ] parce qu'il n'y avait pas de film
pour nous et c'est comme ça que fait
mais j'ai rencontré felli mis dans
l'embarras courbes divines et jetta et
mais qu'est ce que tu fais toi et ligne
ebay se fait rien mais j'attends un rôle
il m'a engagé comme stagiaire et après
j'ai travaillé visconti dans senso alors
il y avait il fallait un acteur pour
jouer le doge de venise
il lui a envoyé un acteur de la comédie
italienne était mauvais comme un cochon
alors il me dit les queen on me dit il
va chercher un job alors je suis parti
sur as à venir sur la place à main j'ai
vu un espèce de gondolier qui étaient là
avec sa grenoble et il avait l'air
d'andorge je les attrape et je vous dis
bien et c'est lui qui a fait le rôle et
c'est comme ça que depuis que je suis
rentré en france je n'ai pris que bourg
souvent que des gens dans la rue et des
gens qui avaient des têtes qui me
plaisait donc excité c'est la méthode
fellini ça
j'ai eu la chance si vous voulez de
changer les gens au lieu de faire
dépendre des impôts ville pour faire un
paysan stupide et c'est à moi je lui ai
fait faire un professeur de philosophie
alors si vous voulez le changement de
coordonnées ce qu'on appelle le contre
emploi afin que l'ensemble des acteurs
aiment le travail avec moi en disant par
exemple catherine deneuve qui était la
blonde un peu et me l'envoyer dans les
salons de coiffure aussi au jour de
france
et bien j'en ai fait une fille qui était
biffi qui avait aucun rapport avec la
fille blonde qu'on connaissait donc ça
lui a plu
et alors j'ai du mal à tomber des
vedettes parce qu'on les empreintes et
isabelle huppert main armée si oui il y
en a plus de lait alors là je me prends
un type un chanteur qui s'appelle
qu'aligne alors il essaie lui la vedette
mon fils après j'ai eu une hilary
strupar roumanoff même je me suis tapé
au moins deux ans j'ai encore line
renaud et après j'ai balasko oublier
tous ces gens là c'est vous voulez tout
ça ça me parait que les acteurs
d'aujourd'hui ils viennent sur mon
plateau quelques fois qu'il connaît pas
et c'est mes voeux net
mais est-ce que c'est des vedettes j'en
sais rien et ma tronche je le connais
très bien macro pour la bonne raison que
les communes quand il avait 14 ans parce
que moi j'ai tourné mon premier film
harry caine d'amour d'ailleurs on a
tourné à amiens
résultat des courses je suis devenu une
personnalité amiens et on allait souvent
dans un ciné club amiens et qu'est ce
qu'il y avait assez des clubs il y avait
macro il avait 14 ans et alors après je
les vues après le quinté dans la vie 18
et puis un jour j'ai plus vu et on m'a
des miss est mariée avec son professeur
et après je les retrouvais hausse le 16
septembre 2016 je l' ai vu il m'a revue
il a tout mais finale qu'on ferait que
josé montrer et il était resté fan de
mes filles parce qu'il les voyait
justement dans ce ciné club est alors un
moment donné on est allé à la tour
montparnasse qu'il a quitté bercy et il
me téléphone libyen la tour montparnasse
il avait un état-major la ml on va faire
un film sur moi il faut que je fasse un
film sur sa compagne et puis finalement
après l'exemple sarkozy avec son hit en
plus pas lyon il a dit ah non je vais
pas faire ça on va demander où j'ai
trouvé le pognon etc
alors finalement
on n'a pas fait le film
[Musique]
je pense qu'aujourd'hui le cinéma est
plus facile à cause de l'année des
moyens qui sont plus c'est plus facile
d'avoir une petite caméra
les grosses caméras qu'on avait les
projecteurs il fallait quatre personnes
pour porter alors automatiquement il ya
du monde
[Musique]
alors je suis assez optimiste pour les
jeunes d'aujourd'hui j'en vois beaucoup
ils viennent me voir pour me demander
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire et je leur
dis vous pouvez vous passer de la salle
de la télévision de tout et vous pouvez
retourner et ça c'est à la portée des
jeunes d'aujourd'hui ils peuvent faire
des films
à l'époque tous les films que ce soit le
mien ce soit celui de lelouch et les
terrasses étaient des films très bon
marché aujourd'hui moi je dis à des
jeunes pour quinze mille balles vous
pouvez faire un film pour 15000 euros
il ya quelque chose d'étrange dans ma
vie c'est que si vous voulez j'ai fait
toujours des petits films par an parmi
camarades mais mais l' avantage que j'ai
c'est que les plus grands musiciens les
plus grands opérateurs et les plus
grands acteurs sont venus travailler
dans ces conditions difficiles on est
devenu célèbre pour des films qu'il ne
coûtait rien et aujourd'hui on nous
demande de faire des films très chers
alors c'est idiot mais c'est
complètement fou
[Musique]